[Music]
How are you greetings by Cristian Cásseres with
his brief News Now program in
Spanish A person is still in
critical condition after being shot outside
the palace The Metropolitan Police
report that they are continuing to investigate
a confrontation between two groups
within the area of ​​the  casino in beni
ser when they were escorted from the
property they fought again and that's
when according to authorities someone pulled out
a gun and one person was injured the
gunman was arrested
a new vaccination center opened its
doors today at the bank this will be
operating from monday  to Friday and will
replace the you clinic itself and
may increase its hours as
demand increases people
eligible under state requirements
can now get vaccinated at this site
including educators visit
disney.com for more information and the
martin luther memorial parade
king junior due to the pandemic this
year will be virtual now these are
images of the  sfile from last year with
everything will start at 10 in the morning
through king week las vegas' dotcom and
then there will be a documentary you
can also see it through facebook and youtube
and the security that is increasing in the
city and all over the  country due to
political attention in downtown las
vegas the windows are sealed in the
federal building which also includes a
fence in the surroundings several businesses
are also taking the same
precautions before possible riots
those merchants taking these
security measures hope to be able to
reopen very soon and  finally
today is anticipated to be a very
pleasant and sunny day temperatures will
reach almost 70 degrees due to
winds and also with light winds
we are watching for a possible system
for this weekend that could
result in rain for our region and
snow for the eastern mountains  It is your brief
informative of Spanish illustrators I am
Cristian Cásseres happy Monday
[Music]